men shouldn't even get married to women
I'm G be honest I gotta be honest on the
show you say men shouldn't get married
to women not in 2023 there's no
incentive for you to get married to
women there's no benefit for you to get
married to women how do you feel that
way it's not a feeling it's it's a
knowledge there is no benefit name one
benefit that a man gets marrying women
if you're not factoring in your emotions
then yeah that makes sense what do you
mean like you like you just said like
well yes marriage is a is often known as
a business
proposal put a pause there by whom by
whom is it even back in the olden days
when when marriages would be uh
contracted for political alliances or
they never didn't refer to it as a
business it wasn't like just a purely
commercial clinical Endeavor it's so low